a state senator running for North Las
Vegas mayor speaking out tonight right
now her son is in jail Pat Spearman says
her son 21 year old neon Shay was
arrested after he shot her nephew inside
her home last night it is NewsHour 8
news now investigators broke this
morning Sasha Loftus joins us from the
north Las Vegas Community Correctional
Center now with more
state senator Pat Spearman made it clear
today that this is quote not about
politics and said she will not be
dropping out of the North Las Vegas
Mayoral race now she addressed the
shooting which reportedly happened at
her home last night her son 21-year-old
neon Shay Osborne was arrested for
shooting her nephew David Spearman says
David is expected to be okay other
family members tell me he was shot in
the hip and will soon have surgery
Spearman was visibly emotional today as
she spoke about how gun violence has
impacted her family we're struggling
right now
Beyonce made a very poor decision
and he'll have to face the consequences
as a mother
I support both the justice system
and my son it is important to note
Osborne does have a criminal history
connected to firearms in 2020 court
records show He was ordered to continue
mental health counseling and forfeit any
Firearms he had Osborne is facing
multiple charges including attempted
murder battery with a deadly weapon and
firing a gun into an unoccupied vehicle
or structure reporting in North Las
Vegas tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now